welcome back today i want to talk about
a movie i saw over the weekend
it's really ticking off cultural elites
it is hillbilly elegy
first this video is sponsored by my
bookie now if you haven't already seen
hillbilly elegy stop the video right now
i'm going to spoil it for you
spoiler alert it's been spoiled you're
warned okay so here is a
quick overview of the plot which is
based on a book by jd vance the book is
called hillbilly lg was a huge
bestseller so like three million copies
and basically hollywood picked up the
rights to this on the heels of the 2016
election when people believing this was
sort of the decoder ring
for the white working class vote as
we'll discuss later reviewers no longer
like the idea that anybody should even
examine that white working class vote
and so instead they've decided that the
movie's really bad in any case let's do
the plot
real fast so the main character is jd
vance okay he's played by a couple of
characters young jd vance and then older
jd vans young jd vance is owen ostellos
i think it's how it's pronounced
and older jd vance is gabriel basso
young jd vance obviously growing up poor
in ohio in sort of a burned-out rust
belt town and obviously he has
appalachian roots
as well and then older jd vance has made
it to yale law school and so basically
this is the story of how he got from
being in a burned-out town with a drug
addict mother to being at yale law
school so
you've got youngjady vance you got older
jd vans then you have amy adams who
plays bev that's his mom his mom
had him when she was a kid you know 18
years old essentially
and has become a drug addict and
a child abuser i mean is really the best
way to to view it glenn close
plays his grandmother who is bev's mom
who is in a relationship with papa
uh papa dies about halfway through the
movie glenn close's mama is the heroine
of the story she is in the book as well
she's sort of the person who who teaches
jd that he has to break the cycle
of cultural impoverishment that he has
been sort of ensconced in
that's the theme of the book the theme
of the book in hillbilly elegy is that
there are cultures of poverty that exist
outside
of various minority communities that
exist in the white community they lead
to economic
depression they lead to people making
bad choices they lead to opioid
addictions and heroin addictions
and all sorts of other addictions and
they ruin lives and you have to make
actual individual decisions
that are good in order to get out of
that and you need good influences like
mamoy
who is played by glenn close here
looking exactly
like uh like jd vance's actual
grandmother haley bennett plays lindsay
who's jd vance's older sister and who
sort of takes care of him and fends off
bev older jd vance has a girlfriend his
name is usha
eventually usha in real life is jd
vance's wife
and ron howard of course is is the
director and i will say the performances
across the board are very very very good
in particularly glenn close
as mamaw is really strong and people are
acting like it's a caricature but
i've talked to jd vance and jd has
suggested that
actually that's kind of what his
grandmother was like amy adams's
performance i mean she is
she is transformed i mean amy adams is a
beautiful woman she plays somebody whose
beauty has been
completely washed out by life she is
tremendous
in the film now there is no question
whatsoever
that if this film had not been seen as a
sort of referendum on trump voters it
would have gotten sterling critical
reaction
no question right if this had been a
play on how trump had ignored
rural voters then it would have done
great if all these people at the end had
voted for joe biden
all the critics would have been like
amazing amazing stuff
but because the book and then eventually
the movie were deemed to be
a sort of examination of the trump voter
you cannot portray trump voters
sympathetically and so there's this vast
gap between the critical reaction to the
film
and the audience reaction now if you're
the audience and you watch this movie
it really is not political it is just an
up by the bootstrap story of a kid who
grows up in rough circumstances and is
guided by his
grandmother toward a better life and
makes better decisions and how you break
cycles of cultural poverty
but because it was perceived to be a
pro-trump piece even though trump has
never mentioned it has nothing to do
with trump
the the basic idea of the critics is
that it is very very bad
it's very bad in fact if you want to see
you know sort of one screenshot of the
two americas look at the rotten tomatoes
score versus the audience
score on rotten tomatoes it's like 26
positive for the critics
on rotten tomatoes and 81 positive for
the audience
on rotten tomatoes you don't see that
sort of gap particularly often except
when the critics have decided to let
their politics infuse how they cover the
film
okay so here's what some of the critics
were saying so darren franich of
entertainment weekly said howard thinks
he's making an inspirational tale
he doesn't realize it's an american
horror story um
no i mean there's a lot of horrifying
stuff in the film but
what dirt and french is actually
objecting to in reality is the same
thing that so many people on the left
object to which is that the story jd
vance's story
really is about the idea that individual
decision making can overcome cultural
impoverishment
richard brody from the new yorker says
with his soupy and personal
manipulations of memory and experience
void of the birds that attached them to
the world at large howard whether
intentionally or not
has made a libertarian's fantasy not
sure how it's a libertarian fantasy
considering it never actually talks
about
government interventionism it doesn't
suggest as the book does that welfare
may in fact be a detriment to people who
are making bad decisions
it doesn't talk about welfare at all it
just says that family
can help you get through hard times and
strong family members can help you
pick up the pieces and make a better
life for yourself but apparently that is
now libertarian fantasy
you see for our entertainment critics
the only movies that are worthy of being
made
are movies where america sucks and
america's suckiness
can only be cured by either some sort of
woke cultural moment or by massive
government interventionism
allison wilmore from new york magazine
says the film is like a package of
assorted chicken parts that can't be
assembled back into something
approximating the shape of an actual
animal there's way too much of some
stuff while certain essentials are
missing
entirely now let me just point out that
if the movie
had hewed closer to the book if it had
included all of the cultural commentary
about the evils of the welfare state and
about the failures
of governments who fill in for church
and schools and local institutions
the critics would have hated it even
more instead they like movies again that
are really about how america sucks
and uh the only way that these rural
people can
do better is by escaping their roots
leaving them behind and becoming
members of the left right or where
everybody in these towns is treated not
with any sort of sympathy but simply
with malevolence like vox recommended
that you watch winter's bone instead
which is a very cynical take
on people who live outside america's
major cities
so how exactly have some of the people
from hollywood in the film reacted to
the negative criticism
well many of them are not even defending
the film so amy adams said i would never
presume
to say what critics should or shouldn't
do everybody has a voice and can use it
how they choose to use it
let me just say if somebody had
criticized any other amy adams film this
way she'd probably suggest
that the critics had an inherent bias
but nobody will ever say that in
hollywood because of course
a lot of the people who signed up for
this thing didn't think it was political
ron howard obviously didn't think it was
political
he appeared on cbs this morning on
tuesday and he said i do feel like
they're looking at political thematics
they may
or may not disagree with that honestly
are not really reflected or not front
and center
of this story and that's kind of right
so ron howard kind of
in the movie he kind of strips all of
the politics from the story
because ron howard is sort of just a
good democrat and he sees it as an
uplifting story
and not just an uplifting story but a
good commentary on how you can make good
decisions
which last i checked used to be
something that liberals shared with
conservatives
but we've moved beyond that we'll get
some more of this in just one second
folks but first let me talk about why
betting can be kind of a fun thing so
right around election time there were
these presidential debates i bet on them
i used my friends over at my bookie they
had a bunch of prop bets on the election
it was a lot of fun
actually i've been betting on sports as
well putting a little money on the line
and can sometimes spice things up but
the christmas holidays right around the
corner my bookie has been in a giving
mood
a 250 risk-free bet on thanksgiving
boosted odds and free bets every hour of
black friday and
they continue to give away more freebies
for cyber monday for a sports book
that's supposed to be in the business of
making money they were giving it away
which is just one of the reasons why
i've been rolling with my bookie this
season the fact is
if you're going to put some action on
the games whether you're betting nfl
ncaa college ball college hoops whatever
your preference you want to do it with a
great brand like my bookie make your
deposit using the promo code shapiro and
they will match you halfway to give you
a head start on building your bankroll
put in 200 bucks get an extra 100 bucks
to play with joining and depositing is a
simple process it's quick
more importantly when it's time to get
paid that is just as quick treat
yourself get some extra cash in your
pocket this holiday season
by investing in your intuition it's not
just winter season it's winning season
so bet
win get paid with my bookie there has
been this cultural transformation
between when the book came out and when
the movie came out
that has happened and it turned
hillbilly elegy from a
good book that liberals liked to read to
a bad book that should never be read
because hillbilly elegy suggests a
couple of things
one again you can make good decisions
that overcome your past and two
that rural white people ought to be
understood and both of those are
premises
that the left has decided to deride
completely rural white people in the
view of the leftist cultural elites are
not worthy of understanding because
after all
they are members of the white privileged
sect of the united states all
institutions were built for their
benefit
and second even these people cannot pick
themselves up by their bootstraps
because no one is able to be picked up
by their own bootstraps hillary clinton
you know she she used to actually tout
hillbilly elegy but what she said about
hillbilly elegy
is essentially what the left
eventually took away from hillbilly
elegy which is that all these people
don't deserve any sympathy at all
right clinton wrote about hillbilly
elegy quote a culture of grievance
victimhood and scapegoating
has taken root as traditional values of
self-reliance and hard work have
withered there's a tendency towards
seeing every problem as somebody else's
fault
whether it's obama liberal elites in big
cities undocumented immigrants taking
jobs minority groups soaking up
assistance
or me right that is the way that hillary
clinton sees the people in the movie so
it's no wonder that the critics who also
see these people that way are very upset
with any movie that treats them as human
beings with actual problems
and who actually are capable of making
better decisions so back to the critics
so the vulture which ran like 83 pieces
about how terrible
the film is which is how you know the
film is not bad it's actually quite good
sarah jones writes the hillbilly elegy
phenomenon is frustrating for many
reasons
as a film it's irresponsible even
grotesque and the memoir of the movie is
based on filters author jd vance's
personal experiences
through right-wing tropes about poverty
and social collapse see the movie's bad
because the book is bad because jd vance
is himself a conservative who's written
for national review here's the key line
both the netflix adaptation in the book
says this columnist for vulture are
unnecessary nobody needed to suddenly
understand the appalachian region or its
problems because appalachian studies is
a real field of scholarship
you can get degrees in it oh weird
because like um i noticed that black
studies is also a field of scholarship
and yet every single movie about the
hardship that black people experience in
the united states is celebrated by
people over at vulture
weird seems like vulture only wants to
hear about one
group of people in the united states why
because the basic supposition
again is that if you're from appalachia
and you have had a bad life
and you grew up in a culturally
impoverished circumstance you're still
not a victim because you're white
the atlantic took a somewhat different
attack here in their review they say the
film and book need appalachia to be poor
broken and dirty because they depend on
us believing that the mountains are
somewhere we want vance to escape
they need to frame poverty as a moral
failing of individuals as opposed to
systems
because they have to imply that
something about vance's character
allowed him to get away from his
hillbilly roots okay now num
quick quick note something about vance's
character did allow him to get away from
his hillbilly roots
because he is one of a rather small
number of people who have gotten away
from hillbilly roots and made it to yale
law
i mean that is kind of a unique story is
it not so if you were just
you know a natural creation of the
system you'd expect that a lot of people
from this neighborhood would have ended
up at
yale law but according again to this
columnist for the atlantic
hillbilly elegy has to simplify people
and problems of appalachia because it
has decided to tell the same old pull
yourself up by your bootstraps narrative
that so many of us reject ah that's the
key
right you reject the narrative therefore
you reject the movie you don't like the
idea that people can actually make good
decisions and make their life better
and therefore the movie is bad okay
alyssa wilkinson at vox.com
talks in her review about one particular
scene so there's a scene in the movie
where it's in the book two where jd
vance goes to a fancy dinner and he
doesn't know how to use all the various
forks
at the table because that's not how he
grew up in the book
people he starts telling people about
his background and they're kind of
interested in it
um and uh and in the movie people sort
of look askance at him
so here's her description she says in
the movie vance's story plays out quite
differently
after an emergency call to his
girlfriend jd sits at the dinner table
of fellow students and attorneys from
high-powered law firms he is nervous
while making conversation he says he is
from ohio and that his grandfather moved
there from kentucky's hill country to
work in a steel mill a quiet falls over
the table
everyone glances at each other knowingly
nobody says anything they change the
subject while jd sits crestfallen and
mortified i yelled at the screen
when i saw that yelling happened
multiple times throughout the movie
and yet that's exactly why the scene
rang so false it seems impossible
everyone at the table would take jd's by
a graphical note as embarrassing instead
as vance himself points out in his book
his background makes him intriguing
someone different from the usual bunch
the movie can't seem to imagine that
however it's writing feels vague and
hazy unacquainted with the world it's
portraying etcetera etcetera okay so
here's the thing i went harvard law
school i've been in this particular
world here's what actually happens in
that scene so in that scene jd vans sits
down at the table
he's going through the forks and as he's
going through the forks he's talking
with people
and he brings up the fact that he has
sort of this hillbilly background and
people are kind of awkward about it and
then he mentions that his family is
descended from sort of the hatfield
mccoy
stuff and people start getting
interested they actually do start
getting interested
and then one person at the table says
well it must be kind of relief to get
out of
you know hillbillytown and jd vance gets
offended
okay this is called a dramatization for
the movies but
are we supposed to pretend that there is
no scorn for people in rural appalachia
at yale law school or at harvard that
they don't call people rednecks
at harvard law school or yale law school
they do i went to harvard law school
there is obviously a certain level of
cultural sneering that exists for people
who live
outside the big cities and don't abide
by all of the cultural niceties
of the of the left at these major
universities
so to pretend that jd vance would have
been welcomed with open arms in all of
his conservative glory his ex-military
glory because of course he had served in
the military as well
is really quite silly i think what the
movie brings out is it brings out the
subtext right i mean the subtext is
that people will treat you tolerantly
but then behind closed doors they'll be
like
oh that redneck there's a lot of that
there is a lot of that that happens
in the upper echelons of the educational
world
okay so here's the deal the movie is
actually good and if you didn't care
about the politics of the movie
then you'd just see it as an empowering
personal story of how a person
rose out of tragic circumstances a
mother who was a drug addict
growing up in poverty you know being
taken out of his mother's home by his
grandmother
grandmother and grandfather having their
own set of circumstances that his
grandmother got pregnant when she was
13.
right and that that's a great story
that's it's a great story it's well
acted it's well shot it's well produced
ron howard's a good director
that's the bottom line but the media
cannot accept that this is a good movie
because to accept that this is a good
movie you have to accept a baseline
value that left and wright used to agree
on which that america is a place
in which people can rise and are capable
of making good decisions and are capable
of moving beyond their personal
circumstance and cultural circumstances
that's a message that the left
completely rejects
completely rejects and they particularly
reject it if you're talking about white
people who apparently are not deserving
of any coverage at all as that vulture
column suggests
because after all white people are the
most privileged among us in american
society so why even bother covering
this sort of stuff in the first place
just a quick note here that's how you
got trump
keep going with the sort of cultural
sneering at everybody who does not fit
your bill of the new woke coalition and
see how it works out for you
cultural arbiters in the in the
entertainment media
alrighty if you enjoyed this video make
sure that you tune in tomorrow for the
ben shapiro show sunday special
we actually interview jd vance we're
going to go through his personal story
talk about what it was like to work on
the movie the critical reception
to the movie what messages was he
actually trying to push his take on
trump's america we'll get to all of that
on the sunday special it's fascinating
jd's a really interesting dude
so make sure that you check that out on
the sunday special this week so
what did you guys think of the movie
were the critics right let me know down
below if you want me to review more
movies like this make sure to subscribe